she truly is a queen today Daenerys
Targaryen what an amazing character out
there over the water and we're just
waiting for her to arrive right with
these dragons above her Dany is perhaps
most intriguing character try to match
up historically Joan of Arc of courses
is one that you want to compare Dany to
prom of course is she gets burned and
she doesn't come out of the flames with
dragons
Dany of course does if we are gonna say
that Westeros is a sort of mirror image
of the wars the roses and there's one
character that Dany looks very very much
like except is not a woman it's Henry
Tudor who spent a lot of his life in
exile Henry the seventh who was known as
Henry Tudor before he became King of
England spent most of his life hiding in
France kind of like viserys and danerys
when they're hiding with Illyrio it
won't be long now soon you will cross
the Narrow Sea and take back your
Father's throne Henry the seventh was
hiding abroad to avoid being captured
and killed the whole is pregnant you're
speaking of murdering a child I want him
dead
mother and child both is that plain
enough for you but he came back
it's fulfil the prophecies ancient Welsh
prophecies and when he marched back to
England above his armies fluttered a
flag with a dragon on it but I don't
think you can just say that Danny is
Henry Tudor and that's that because I
think there's a lot of classical ancient
history that's been put into that
character as well so there's a little
bit of Alexander the Great
it was a king who conquered huge swathes
of territory and took lots of different
people's along with him but I think
there's a lot of cleopatra in there as
well
very very strong female character who is
in some sense is always struggling with
the consequences and the obligations of
power I did not take up residence in
this pyramid so I could watch the city
below decline into chaos we see in
season 5 Danny's living in a pyramid
well Cleopatra came from Egypt and I
don't want to be to flip about it but I
sense a lot of Cleopatra folded in a big
dollop of Henry Tudor with his dragons
flying above her a big part of Danny's
story is journey round slavers Bay and
her kind of puzzling out her
relationship with the slaves who machine
she gathered into her army some say the
unsullied are the greatest soldiers in
the world
the greatest slave-soldiers in the world
slave soldiers they go way back
and so the unsullied can be matched up
to the troops that the Spartans had they
could be matched up to the man Lupe's
were probably our most famous slave
armies one of the most successful
Islamic dynasties in the Crusades were
slave armies the Mamluks
and I think when we look at the
unsullied I see a lot of the Mamluks in
there as well as a bit of the Spartans
people who've been selected purely for
their fighting ability they may suit my
needs tell me of their training
well the unsullied are loosely based on
some of the slave soldiers of history
the the mem looks of Egypt
the Janissaries of the Turkish Empire
similar groups who were children taken
from their parents as slaves and trained
solely for the purpose of being warriors
slaves don't like being slaves and when
a person like Danny comes in and offers
them a freedom almost everyone
especially the young ones are going to
want to get freedom to pursue their own
interests I don't expect the wise
masters to be happy
slavery made them rich I ended slavery
they do not ask for the return of
slavery they ask for the reopening of
the fighting blades
the fighting pits where slaves fought
slaves to the death having humans
slaughter each other for entertainment
that's gone on for centuries but I think
you know if you were gonna pick a time
when it had been very popular its
ancient Rome's now it's the Colosseum
so the fighting pits the gorge is
invented I think hark directly back to
ancient Rome it was actually the
Etruscans who begin the gladiatorial
games and of course the Romans conquered
the Etruscans they picked up some of
their habits including
that one those games the auditory
matches they're pretty fierce it's a
sport but it's a of course it's a blood
sport if you make a mistake you die
[Applause]
slaves are given it's a possible promise
that they're gonna get freedom as far as
we know very few do one of the
historical influences on the dothraki
well I think you can see a lot of the
Mongols in the Dothraki you know in the
13th century when Genghis Khan and his
successors were burning everywhere from
Beijing to Baghdad they also have a lot
of the Huns in them who were a similar
nomadic horse people who came out of
Asia a thousand years earlier the Huns
like the Dothraki spent all their time
on horseback they slept on horseback
they made love on horseback they
negotiated diplomatic treaties on
respect the ceremony is over didn't say
anything did he like her trust me your
grace if he didn't like her we'd know I
think he said the nomadic warrior
perfectly whether it's a Mongol or a
Honora any of those guys that come off
the central steps they move as
communities everybody is tied to the way
of life women are every bit as as wild
as the men are but I think there's also
quite a bit of Native American culture
that's that's feeding into the Dothraki
what we know of they say the Comanche
tribe is
at a very well-groomed culture there was
a great pride in the Warriors appearance
we know that the Dothraki grow their
hair and their braids until they're
defeated in battle men cut them off I
think this real concern with the
physical projection of the warrior
spirit there's a little bit of Native
American there but I took some elements
that were purely fantasy to try to
create something that was grounded in
reality but was not necessarily just a
Xerox of reality
I think when you look at the cities of
slavers Bay it's really reminiscent of
what I always imagined ancient Egypt
must have looked like very exotic the
people very different to the rest of the
Mediterranean and this really huge
monumental architecture that just looms
over everyone who approaches it there's
so much of Cleopatra and North Africa in
the ancient world all in that little
area of slavers Bay it's and it's a
really great counterpoint to the rest of
Westeros I think you could look at the
Wars of the Roses and try and work out
where George is going I think you could
do that I think you'd also run the risk
of going insane everything in the world
is grist for the mill be it you know
real life or contemporary events or
history I mean it's all stuff that you
can take and rework and make into
stories whatever happens in the end in
Westeros
maybe it will map the wards the Roses
maybe will be sitting there okay this
was exactly what happened or maybe it'll
just be whatever George wants it to be
it occurred to me that if I tweaked it
just a little and I added some fantasy
elements and change the characters then
now you have all the appeal of the Wars
of the Roses but you also have
unpredictability you don't know who's
gonna win you don't know who's gonna die